go put on one of my ties we're going to
midnight mass not a tractor auction the
show starts off bringing you right into
the beauty of family dysfunction this is
what happens at the holidays we get
together we argue people file for
divorce and your character skip or Kayla
piece right from the start gets hit with
it right in front of the family the most
awkward moment you've ever had at a
family holiday
oh so me my dad got into a fight
we're from the East Coast so there's
like no elephants in the room in our
home so it's like if we're feeling a
certain way we do not hide it it's like
we we still have that East Coast in us
where we're just gonna like yell about
it get over it because we love each
other and it's like okay it's cleared
out and my sister's boyfriend was not a
big fan because he was just like it was
awkward for him that I was like
emotional and like crying and my dad
like I didn't agree with him on things
really kind of stupid but it was mainly
which is like so this show it was like
the pressure of the holiday specifically
caused us to argue about something and
so he left and I felt through my sister
because I was just like I was like oh I
feel bad but like also if he can't
really get this like she can't be a part
of the family I'm sorry
by the way that is literally the theme
of the show is your new man oh yeah who
wants to propose yeah has to hack it
with this fan you gotta roll with the
punches god yeah do you guys have any
advice on like how to enter a new family
because it you're both married right
yeah how do you blend it how do you make
it happen especially at the holidays I
think like one thing that cuz this is
very new to me but one thing I've been
thinking about is is just like going
with the flow you know like not trying
to impose any expectations or anything
but just like being curious about how
another family does things
and then also like not putting any time
pressure on like everything feeling
right immediately you know like if
you're married to somebody you're gonna
be with them forever like you have you
have a lifetime to like build up those
sort of traditions and experiences and
so I think I'm really like excited to
continue to have those experiences with
my in-laws and they're great people
they're awesome but I think also just
like not putting the pressure on things
being perfect like you got a power
through just maybe don't staple the
father-in-law in the head right I just
don't give me scissors either because I
am so dysfunctional like that no any
advice from you Ashley how did you and
the man make it work
you know I think that I obviously I
think I just said this last time showed
signs that I did not want a part for my
son Curtis missing it was like a very
big wake up call when we got married I
was like oh we are going to have to
split holidays but his family is so
amazing that they are you know I think
it we were blessed with like his family
is like all about boundaries and my
family is not about boundaries so it's
an easy balance of like being able to be
like cool let's celebrate you know a
couple days early with his family but
also we know we're making our own
tradition and so we like to have
everybody all of our families over on
Christmas Day at our house so I think
it's just kind of like learning like we
have become our own family and so it's
just like okay like what do we want to
do as a couple and like how we involve
our families I love that you don't want
to leave your family because you want to
be with them and fight like East
Coasters do ya just wanna argue how did
you handle filming this show when it's
totally not Christmastime but you're in
the spirit even being here today I'm
like it was summer and it had a 100
degrees as we were filming oh my god let
me tell you freezing on set yeah where
it's so cold but the problem with our
dressing rooms were outside of the stage
so we would be hit with the heat and
realized it was summer and your ring
like a knit wool sweater and then it was
funny like for me cuz like I just come
from the east coast yeah
already was like freezing until April in
Massachusetts when there's still snow on
a which I still don't understand but so
when I found out I got the show it was
still snowing and I was like this is
interest it's gonna have it super long
winter right now if you guys just yeah
thinking about your Christmas presents
for six months like I know exactly what
I would actually know I mean honestly
like it's just when you're obviously
working you're just constantly like I
don't know for me I've been thinking
like I want to do some of the traditions
the Quinn family does like I want to
like take each moment in their like they
do and it's just like you know forget
the presents that's like let's be as
present as as they are an inch of each
episode forget the presents be present
know that's getting presents this year
so in the mario she's gonna be with me
no news for you just arguments by the
way Dennis Quaid I mean he just is so
great on this show was he kind of a
patriarch on set as well what was it
like having Dennis Quaid his dad he was
really looking out for us you know like
if somebody was going through something
in their life I think he really went
above and beyond to make sure that
people were feeling like okay and
included yeah he's such a good person
and I mean he's an amazing and talented
person as well but he really was like
our dad on set and he's just yeah I love
him like I absolutely love working with
him he's also like a dad and just like
cheering us on on whenever he thought we
were really funny in a scene he would
just be like such a champion and like
you know sometimes like you know really
yeah he literally would take moments
sometimes and stop on my dresser and be
like I just want to tell you like you
were so funny and I was like like who
does that like who takes you know a
moment in time and just like tells you
like that on their way to their dressing
room but it's just really sweet which is
so funny because his character is so
this laying down the law yes I say dad a
very talented actor that Dennis Quaid
yeah do you guys have any moments that
stick in your mind of a time when your
parents really lay down the law said
this is what you're doing
I mean my my dad is a lot like Don Quinn
in the show like he's protective he it's
just like underneath his roof is Argus
no but it's like I think that for I
think it's something that I really
respect though because I think that you
know especially as like a child actor
and I grew up in this business
I really respect my parents and I and
it's because like they have certain
things that my dad is like no you're not
gonna just go out till all hours when I
was growing up and you know like I
you're gonna come home at a certain time
and I don't care that you make tons of
money like you're gonna do this like
it's just like a very much like you know
he really set me up I think for success
like I had to work in clothing stores
but a regular school my whole life even
though I was in the business and I
really respect at the time I did it I
was like why are you making me gonna
rather school like I'd rather be
homeless folder
why do I have to work in clothing stores
like I do TV shows and I really respect
it because it it really made me who I am
you call yourselves carolers
[Music]